to prepare you for the Last of Us part 2
let's take a look back and recap the
story at the Last of Us and its DLC left
behind The Last of Us begins in
September 2013 with father and daughter
Joel and Sarah it's the night of the
outbreak in the whole world as being
overrun by a fungal infection that turns
people erratic and violent along with
Joel's brother Tommy they attempt to
make their way out of town
unfortunately Sarah doesn't make it in a
shot by one of the US soldiers trying to
contain the outbreak fast forward 20
years and Joel is a smuggler living in a
Boston quarantine zone he and tests a
fellow smuggler and Joel's partner meet
up with Robert who owes them some guns
Robert admits he sold their guns to the
fireflies a militia group rebelling
against the overbearing military
presence and quarantine cities and tests
deals with it in her own unique way Joel
and Tess
try to get their guns back from the
fireflies leader Marlene who will only
return them if they smuggle Ellie a 14
year old girl out of the city Ellie was
bitten by an infected three weeks prior
and hasn't churned typically people
churn in one to two days so Marlene
believes Ellie is the key to finding a
vaccine Joel and Tess are tasked with
bringing Ellie to the Capitol building
and meeting with a group of fireflies
there but when they arrive all the
fireflies are dead it's revealed that
Tess was been and she urges Joel to take
Ellie to his brother Tommy Tommy now
lives in Wyoming and as a former member
of the fireflies should know where to
take Ellie when a group of soldiers show
up tests attempts to hold them off
giving Joel and Ellie time to escape but
at the cost of her life Joel and Ellie
head to a nearby town to meet with an
old friend bill bill owes Joel some
favors and Joel hopes to cash them in to
get a card that'll help take him in
Ellie to Tommy there's a military
caravan that got overrun by clickers and
Bill thinks they can take that battery
and put it in another car unfortunately
for them the battery was already taken
but they later learned it was taken by
bill's older partner Frank and the
battery is now sitting in a truck
luckily they're able to get the truck
running and start their journey out west
Joel and Ellie get attacked by a group
of human hunters in Pittsburgh which
totals their car and forces them to
continue on foot here they met Henry and
Sam two brothers who are
also trying to make it out of Pittsburgh
on the way out they are attacked by a
mounted gun truck and are separated with
Henry and Sam leaving them behind Joel
and Ellie become cornered and jump into
the ocean and when Joel wakes up he's on
the beach with not just Ellie but Sam
and Henry after a heated confrontation
the four of them head towards a radio
tower where survivors from Henry and
Sam's group are supposed to meet them
unfortunately along the way Sam gets
bitten unable to face what's about to
happen
Henry shoots Sam and then kills himself
a few months later in the fall Joel and
Ellie make it to Wyoming where they meet
up with Tommy and his wife Maria they
live in the compound of a dam which
they're trying to repair to get
electricity back Tommy initially refuses
to take Ellie to the fireflies for Joel
but eventually realizes he has to do
this Ellie however isn't so keen on the
arrangement and runs away after a heated
argument
Joel decides that he should take Ellie
instead the two have built trust with
each other and Joel's fatherly instincts
begin to bubble to the surface
Tommy informs them that the fireflies
are stationed at the University of
Eastern Colorado
once there they find that the fireflies
have moved to st. Mary's Hospital in
Salt Lake City Utah on the way out
they're attacked and Joel becomes
severely wounded Ellie is able to lead
them to safety but Joel falls
unconscious now in the winter
Elia is searching for food and runs into
two men David and James David agrees to
give Ellie medicine for the meat on her
dear David reveals that it was his men
who Joel and Ellie attack to the
University but initially he chooses not
to kill Ellie Ellie makes it back to
Joel and injects him with the medicine
but David's men Shrek elite down after
taking out a lot of them David catches
her and throws her in a Cell here we
learned that David's group are cannibals
but he wants to keep Ellie alive for
some more unsavoury desires he has she
refuses to comply so the two men tried
to cut her up but she convinces them
that she's infected and uses this to
make her escape David finds her an
abandoned restaurant and locks the door
eventually she takes his machete and
kills him with it Joel now recovered
catches up with her after she murders
David now in the spring Joel and Ellie
are in Utah once inside the hospital
Marlene and forms them that they can
reverse-engineer a vaccine from Ellie
but they have to kill her
to do it Joel after bonding
le as much as he has doesn't allow this
to happen and kills tons of fireflies
including Marlene he grabs Ellie who's
unconscious from being prepped for
surgery and takes her to Tommy's when
Ellie wakes up Joel lies to her and
tells her that there are tons of immune
people like her and due to them not
working the fireflies aren't even
looking for a vaccine anymore
later when Ellie confronts Joel on if
he's telling the truth he affirms his
position and thus ends the first last of
us the additional story DLC left behind
takes place during two different periods
in time the first is right after the
events of the University of eastern
Colorado Ellie finds herself in an
abandoned Colorado mall looking for
medical supplies there's a military
helicopter lodged in the ceiling with
supplies on board that she manages to
get to after fighting her way through
infected and David's men she gets back
to Joel the other part is three weeks
before the events of the game with Ellie
and Riley Riley Ellie's best friend who
she hasn't seen for weeks decides to
surprise visit informs LA that she
joined the fireflies the two sneak out
to an abandoned mall and have some fun
but Riley tells Ellie that she's
actually being assigned to another city
and did all this because she wanted a
chance to properly say goodbye to Ellie
the two share a kiss but the happy
moment unfortunately comes to a quick
close when a swarm of infected busting
this is the moment where Ellie and Riley
get infected and the two decide to live
out the remainder of their time together
except as we know from the main story
Ellie makes it out okay and that
concludes our journey through the Last
of Us there's a four-issue comic book
series that details Ellie and Riley's
relationship before left behind if
you're looking for even more or less of
us content but otherwise you should be
all caught up for part two thanks so
much for watching for more coverage in
The Last of Us
stay tuned to gain spot
[Music]
you